salehi alors comme vous expliquer un peu
plus d'une semaine la vidéo
j'annonçais des vidéos qu'on allait
faire cet été nous arrivons donc à la
série de 32 et nîmes durant
trente-deux jours je donnais des minimes
chaque jour avec les solutions le
lendemain et la nouvelle énigme bien
sûr je donne tout ça ici depuis le
lieu de culte spence à paris et on a
créé un petit peu de luminosité quand
il fait
c'est que je donne la solution d'une
énigme de la veille et quand il fait
jour c'est que je vous donnais
numérique qu'est-ce que je vais faire
moi pendant ses 32 ans déjà je vais
prendre un petit peu de vacances j'ai
préparé aussi de la matière pour la
reprise de fin août au pouvoir attaquer
sereinement la dernière ligne droite du
défi de faire une vidéo par jour
pendant un an merci à vous tous qui
êtes là depuis le départ ou depuis
hier peu importe merci à tous merci
aussi à tous ceux qui ce titre les
vidéos pour les rendre accessibles aux
malentendants ça c'est vraiment génial
comme d'habitude je continuerai à lire
tous vos commentaires sur le fait que la
dérive avant je vais pas répondre à
tout le monde mais en tout cas sachez
qu'avec l'application que sur le
téléphone je lis toujours tous les
commentaires j'espère donc que cette
série spécialement fait pour l'été
dans un format plus léger un espèce de
petit jeu au quotidien vous plaira
beaucoup on a beaucoup de plaisir à
faire c est de la paix c'est parti pour
la première fois se retrouve donc dans
une manif tic
studio de 18 ans * pour la première
énigme de cet été sur les 1 4 pour
trouver des fois ce sera beaucoup trop
dépassera beaucoup trop court essayez
de pages chercher la solution sur
internet regardez plutôt la solution
dans la vidéo que je fais le lendemain
comme ça vous avez trois en même temps
actuels nouvelle énigme premier anime
plutôt tranquille imaginez une voiture
piégée garée à cet emplacement là
précisément
la seule question que je vais vous poser
kelley les libéraux de sa place de
parking
allez-y chercher essayer de trouver vous
pouvez voulant faire son petit bout de
papier pour l'emmener avec vous pour
essayer de le faire de personnes en
même temps évidemment on pourra en
parler dans les commentaires la vidéo
mais si vous voulez qu'on fasse vraiment
ce jeu là durant ces quelques jours
mettez pas la réponse
dans les commentaires laissez plus tôt
les autres chercher des parts compte
n'était que vous vous l'avez trouvé
avec la tête enfin il ya le temps
histoire qu'on puisse suivre tout ça
sorte dès que vous avez trouvé la
bonne réponse
mais bien poussan l'air ce qui permettra
pas pour chaque vidéo quel est le
pourcentage de gens qui ont trouvé par
rapport au nombre de vues profitez du
soleil est passé un très bel et bien
oublié pas de vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir les rendez-vous
de demain après 11 heures jardin